- Dniproupol, bien loin
des combats. C'est ici qu'est
venu se venu se réfugier la chee
la police de la ville,
Yevgenia Ivanchenko, la voici
Puis, à la mi-mars, l'enfer
commence.
voitures ont été détruites par
un tank. Il y a eu deux morts.
fonctions des quelques 300
policiers qui n'avaient plus
qu'une chose à faire : S'évader
pour éviter d'autres ennuis.
Son père est resté là-bas
avec un collègue, il trouve
une voiture en état de marche,e,
mais sans vitres. Et c'est
le parcours du combattant
à travers une vins
à ralentir la caravane.abitantst
à sortir de Marioupol vers
l'Ukraine, par contre les Russes
offre des autobus vers
la Russie. N'ayant pas d'autre
t. Le martyr
de Marioupol continue, on parle
de 20 000 morts.
Yevgenia crois qu'il y en a
plus, si on juge par la taille
de la fosse commune que les
images satellites, 300 m2.
On les soupçonne d
camoufler des massacresukrainiee
dans le dernier bastion,
la scierie Azovstal, pilonné
impitoyablement. Elle a trois
amis, dont elle guette chaque
jour de nouvelles,
à l'intérieur. Ma
enregistre des pertes. Elle est
sûre que l'arméene est
très forte. Patribout des onglee
gravée du nom de Marioupol, ell,
dans la police, quand tout sera
terminé.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-C